[Music]
anger frustration and fear this is the
scene at a local hospital in pakdashed
in the southern part of the capital on
Saturday
three girls schools were attacked on the
same day using what's suspected to have
been poisonous gas
at least 250 students were taken to
hospital
in the city of kovar near the southern
city of Shiraz paramedics tell these
girls don't be afraid Just Breathe
semi-official news agencies reported
attacks in at least 15 provinces all on
Saturday
human rights groups in the country say
at least 40 schools came under attack
parents are demanding answers from
authorities and some came to an
education Ministry Office in the capital
the president has tasked the interior
Ministry with investigating the attacks
they've been happening repeatedly since
November affecting more than 1500 girls
Ibrahim raisy blamed what he called
foreign elements foreign
regarding what's happening in schools
this is an attempt to create fear and
disappointment among our children and
people the enemies trying to create
insecurity
these attacks have increased rapidly
across the country during the past week
no arrests haven't made yet
it is now clear girls education is under
attack in a country with one of the
highest literacy rates among women in
the Middle East these incidents may not
change that fact they have succeeded in
creating panic and fear among many
parents and schoolgirls in Iran
Tehran